what do you think the reason is that
your father saw kept those audio Diaries
that's an interesting question
kept the audio Diaries why did he record
the audio Diaries was his motivation to
record the audio Diaries different from
his motivation to record his phone calls
with cash secretly I would say that the
answer to the audio Diaries in a word is
that he was a narcissist thank goodness
my father was a narcissist I'm sure I'm
part narcissist myself the great thing
about narcissus is they keep everything
they keep a very detailed record of
their lives
it wasn't on the other hand as some
people suspect to some day write a
tell-all book about Johnny Cash that was
not my father style he had sat on this
storage locker for 30 years when he
committed suicide he had plenty of time
to write such a book I believe the
reason he recorded those audio Diaries
whether he was conscious of it or not
was that this was a form of therapy this
was an archetypical 1950s man this was a
time when psychiatrists were taboo and
besides anyone who's seen the film would
know my father as someone who would
never see a psychiatrist or admit that
he couldn't solve his own problem so I
believe and it's evidenced by what you
hear in the film that these diaries are
a way for my father to deal with
emotional baggage as he comes off the
road with cash
he'll recount the previous week or
what's going on with his family or his
own failings now the question of why he
recorded the phone calls is somewhat
different and quite fascinating the
truth is is that it wasn't again to get
the goods on Johnny Cash but I
discovered in going through his material
that he began a practice in the early
60s of having people witnesses
conversations with Johnny you have to
understand that by 1960
or 65 Jonny had developed a split
personality
in fact Johnny himself famously said
that Johnny's the nice guy it's Cash who
causes all the trouble the fact is he
was taking so many pills at that point
that one day he would meet with my
father and my father would say what do
you think let's play Miami on the 27th
and cash would say sure let's do it the
next day Johnny would say I never said
that what are you talking about so my
father began a practice of having June
witnessed their conversations and then
when the technology came along to afford
him to record his phone calls with cash
that was simply an extension of having
backup in case cash should fall off the
wagon and deny having agreed to do
something very smart do you almost feel
that he wanted you to find the audio
tapes I know you said in one scene I
believe that you felt as if he was
actually speaking to you and you played
somewhere it did it sounded like he was
addressing you personally do you think
it's a fair question
and it's certainly a hypothetical one
because no one could possibly know the
answer there are people who are perhaps
spiritual more moreso than I or perhaps
very optimistic who will come up to me
and say you know your father he left
those tapes for you because he wanted
you to reconcile with him in death which
I know not to be true because my father
would if he were walking around he'd
find a way to kill me for touching his
stuff but I do believe that he would
have gotten a big kick out of out of the
movie because again he enjoyed the
attention he did get his Cash's manager
if not being a narcissist and I think
that he would enjoy having been made
sort of his legacy have been assured as
a consequence
you